we have this from timcast.com EU
approves carbon tax for individuals some
officials warn the new CO2 taxes could
be politically suicidal and Spark
widespread protests under the EU
emissions trading system 2
ets2 the new polluter pays taxes will be
imposed on buildings and for
transportation fuels as part of a plan
to reduce Europe's greenhouse gases by
55 percent compared to a 1990 to 1990
Levels by the year 2030. the carbon tax
will impact gas diesel heating fuels
like natural gas making it more
expensive for Europeans to travel and
Heat their homes now we saw when France
tried raising that petrol tax and then
they got the yellow jackets protest for
like two years I don't think this will
go over well but I will just stress to
everyone who is American if you do not
stand up for yourself and for what you
believe in this is coming here next well
there's actual conversations in the
European Union right now warning about a
yellow vest populist Uprising because of
how they're just bleeding the average
person there and I literally wrote
carbon tax because I was going to say
that next without even knowing that you
were pulling up the story because it was
already in my mind another thing I
wanted to bring up really quickly Bill
Gates also is an individual who promised
to give the majority of his wealth away
to charity he has since then doubled his
money it's not a coincidence because
he's launching a lot of scams and when
you look up the larger kind of uh
philanthropy scene when you when you
look at a lot of these people who say
that they give the most usually those
are the some of the most ruthless
Psychopathic business people that you
could ever imagine that are milking the
system abusing the system and this
larger climate change Ponzi scheme is
just a way to try to bleed out the
people take away more money for them and
to control them as a former as a proxy
social credit score system there's a
reason Airlines started calculating your
carbon credit score how much carbon are
you using here there's a reason private
businesses and Banks started to
calculate this on their own initiatives
it wasn't their own initiatives it was
centrally controlled and centrally
pushed out there and this is the slow
creeping Chinese totalitarian Society
society that they're going to be
bringing in everywhere Europe is just a
beginning they're going to be bringing
here bringing it here to the United
States eventually Canada is Right lock
and step with Europe in Canada they've
actually floated is not being
implemented or anything like that but
actually uh capping the number of miles
that an individual may be able to travel
so essentially if you drive for work and
you want to go on vacation for summer
holidays well guess what you can't buy
that plane ticket you've already
exceeded your mile your mile quota and
they've even floated things like oh you
could have cap and trade for individual
miles and oh you have an electric
vehicle well now we can monitor who is
going where and driving what so they
might actually be able to just press a
button and stop your engine to ground
you so that you don't go anywhere this
is terrifying and it's being done in the
name of compassion and I think you know
what I I'm gonna say this if these
policies take hold anywhere it's not
going to be Europe it will be Canada let
me ask you do you think uh maybe 10 20
years you're driving in your Tesla and
then you get a carbon you know energy
consumption warning and it slows you
down and says return home you've
consumed too much energy yeah and it's
like you're at in the arcade if not
we're going to have the Central Bank
digital currency that is deducted from
your account that is linked to your
other otherwise carbon emission
footprint unless you actually comply
that that's overhead there are people
trying to get that done for the Canadian
trucker protest already anyway electric
vehicles that were they were trying to
actually ground them make them unable to
move the state of California the state
of California literally told people stop
charging your electric vehicles why
because their power grid was going down
why because they're going into this
green energy Revolution which is again a
larger carbon tax a larger social credit
score but I'm glad you mentioned
California because because here's how
the global Cascade works on any of these
climatests or even you know beyond
climate policies Europe does something
bone-headed because they have their own
insecurity complexes apologizing for
their own colonialist past or whatever
is going on in Europe California then
copies that European policy California
then becomes competitively disadvantaged
relative to other states but California
which has the largest pension fund
system in the country Calpers uses its
money to get BlackRock and State Street
in Vanguard to then Implement that
through the private sector for the rest
of the country so that is the same
Cascade we see that pattern time and
again which is why every American
citizen should absolutely pay attention
to what is happening in Western Europe
because it's going to find its way into
the United States by the government of
California which then runs through the
money of Calpers which then runs through
the money that streams into the private
sector of the United States that's just
the loop it's sort of the the unpaid the
the unidentified invisible Road of
social policy from Europe into the media
stuff like that because those as ESG
scores I mean people start to wonder why
is Disney going so woke when their
movies keep bombing well it's exactly
because of those investors that are
looking specifically for companies that
are pushing these and it's not for
financial gain because clearly these
companies aren't making money it is
actually an ideological push and I think
you're wrong if you believe that oh uh
money is the ultimate mover and maker
right now because there are people who
are willing to lose a lot of money in
order to push this agenda which is why
I'm also more optimistic on Market
Solutions than I am on Government
Solutions by the way because I don't
know if you I don't know if we haven't
talked about the software but if you
know what strive when everyone's drivers
I mean it's a little bit yeah yeah so my
whole view is
look I said so you're just for people
who aren't aware about what's going on
with the BlackRock problem all right
you've got three asset managers they
manage over 20 trillion dollars okay
it's BlackRock State Street Vanguard
that is by the way the largest private
sector aggregation of capital in human
history I've actually started studying
this going all the way back to the Dutch
East India Company and Beyond this is
the most powerful aggregation of
corporate capital in human history but
they're using the money of those
everyday citizens to tell oil companies
to drill for Less oil tech companies to
adopter racial hiring systems et cetera
et cetera et cetera well if you ask most
people in this country actually give a
homework assignment to anyone watching
the show literally go ask your financial
advisor go ask the person who runs your
401k plan at work was my money used to
vote in favor of a racial Equity audit
at Apple or a emissions cap at Chevron
first thing they'll tell you is they
don't know because they probably don't
tell them to find out you're almost
certain to find out the answer was
directly or indirectly yes
once you know that
it's you got to recognize it is your own
money that is actually being used to
vote for the very policies that we're
sitting here complaining I bet probably
directly or indirectly I'm I would be
willing to bet that most of the three of
you if not all three of you had your own
investment accounts in some way directly
and directly voting for those policies
once people wake up to that reality you
can move your own money in a way that at
least gets much further than the
government's going to get to in the next
24 months I made sure my mine is it by
the way right but so break this down for
us how would your money fall into the
hands of those companies yeah so it's
like a game of Plinko you've seen the
prices right you know that game that you
drop the plinkos yeah it's pretty good
so so there's there's a bunch of
intermediaries so let's say I you know
I'll give you a couple different
Cascades let's say you are working at a
company you put your money in a 401k
account because you put that away
there's a tax advantage associated with
doing so whatever well that's invested
in index funds you don't know who those
index funds are because you have only a
menu that your 401k plan administrator
picks well those index funds tend to be
provided by the three largest asset
enter BlackRock State Street Vanguard
Invesco by the way is number four
they're not much better in this metric
now what do they do they use that money
to buy shares in publicly traded
companies across the American economy
that's what an index fund is you own the
index now with that comes not only a
financial entitlement which is the right
to receive the profits and dividends
that's what you get if you own a share
of a company but also the right to vote
because if you're a shareholder in this
company you have a right to actually
have say who runs the company how much
they're paid and so on however that
voting power rests with the index fund
manager the BlackRock the Vanguard of
the world and what they're doing now is
they're using that share to not vote for
what actually advances the financial
interests of the person that 401k
account but to implement someone else's
political agenda who's that someone else
actually turns out that's it's Calpers
it's California's pension fund system
that's the state of New York expansion
fund system who've explicitly starting
when Trump pulled out of the Paris
climate Accords this is about four years
ago they said that well look if the
government isn't going to address
climate change or racial Injustice then
we in the private sector have to do it
instead so we California and by the way
Norway or whoever else will do the same
thing we're going to pull our money from
you blackrocker Vanguard unless you use
everyone else's money that you manage to
vote this agenda in place and so they
drag everyone else along for the ride
because they know that Mom and Pop
working with their 401k account they're
going to pay attention they don't know
what's going on so it was by design that
that's actually what's implementing this
agenda where if you put it in the ballot
box that say mom and pop would say hell
no if you ask them do you want your
money to be used to implement that same
climate agenda racial Equity agenda they
will still say hell no but little do
they know that they're hard-earned
dollars that they banked away in that
401k account was indeed the very weapon
that was used to implement that agenda
in the first place and it's not just
individuals it's also States it's also
countries entirely just giving all of
their money to these institutions and
not even knowing that they're doing so
and I believe it was West Virginia and
Florida are the only states that kind of
moved out of it away from the ESG score
which I think is worth noting here
because there is a way if people spread
this information enough there is a way
to to move away from the system that we
are incentivizing and giving money to
which is absolutely crazy and I think we
should stop immediately doing so and I
don't mean enemy to you know plug my own
stuff or whatever but just factually
speaking I didn't think I was going to
start another business I thought I was
done I hung the jersey and business
after biotech the reason I came back to
it is literally this is a problem that
is begging to be solved through the
market so that that's literally why I
started strive which is
to be a voice in the market that uses
shareholder power that tells these
companies to knock it off with the
politics and to focus exclusively on
making excellent products and services
to make money and to do it without
having to apologize for it and the irony
is like back in 1990 you would have said
this has been all this is this is the
most boring thing you possibly could do
yet today there is there's all there's
no other major firm I'm aware of that's
actually started doing it and you know
what's funny is we've I mean there's a
million things I would have done
differently three months in we cross
half a billion dollars took JP Morgan
when they entered the ETF business the
exchange rate funded business I'm told
over two years to cross a billion it's
like upstart we're three months in we
crossed half billion because of the
demand of the everyday citizen for this
basic alternative and voice can you
break down in layman's terms what it is
you do yeah so subscribe is basically
the new company I found it it is
competing directly with the likes of
BlackRock and State Street Vanguard
offering index funds ways to invest in
the market to own the companies in these
underlying indices but with a different
mandate to the underlying companies
using not not a gentle ask but using
shareholder power to mandate these
companies to focus exclusively on
products and profits over politics and
social agendas have you talked with uh
anyone in government in West Virginia or
Florida about I've been I've been
talking to people across the states in
in the country and it's been a wake up
it's been an exercise in in waking these
people up to what's happening in their
own backyard now the funny thing is a
lot of these folks are really happy in
red States and otherwise to point the
finger to Blackrock and State Street in
Vanguard and that's fine
when it's a lot harder for them to admit
what's happening in their own backyard
you're talking about the Deep State at
the federal level the Deep state within
the states is actually even more
eye-opening when you look at how Florida
or how even the state of Texas forget
blue States how those States Pension
funds even for the proxies the
shareholder votes that they cast
internally they're every bit as bad as
the ESG industrial complex at BlackRock
racial Equity audits at Amazon civil
rights representative on Facebook's
board without re-electing Peter thieler
Mark Andreessen they say they want to
reelect them they want to appoint a
civil rights representative to
Facebook's board that's the State of
Florida right and so I think that I
think that a lot of conservatives a lot
of red States they're really good at at
pointing out the problem in somebody
else's yard but not good enough at
looking actually at the at the Cesspool
in even their own state governments in
their own backyards and so one of the
things I've been trying to do is is and
I've talked yes to all of these states
and more educating them about what's
even happening in their own little
fiefdom and the more people get educated
the more it becomes difficult for them
not to take action of some kind I think
that's what we're beginning to see if
social media allows you to have a voice
and I I absolutely agree with you I do
believe the market will uh is a way
better solution and should fix
everything but we have a lot of
socialism when it comes to a lot of
these government officials manipulating
the market for their own personal
benefit but at the end of the day for me
personally if you believe the government
is going to solve any problem you're
either insane or delusional so I'm with
you I think what you're doing is
exciting it sounds really awesome to be
honest with you and I think if more
people were aware like hey I'm you know
in in a red state but my retirement is
going to the ESG I think a lot of people
would act on it immediately I would and
I did personally too I have someone that
handles my retirement and I'm like I
don't want my money in any of this
nonsense and he handles it in a way
where he makes sure it doesn't
prioritize a lot of this bigger bullcrap
we talked with the state treasurer from
West Virginia came on the show last week
yeah Riley right you've met him oh yeah
and he was telling the exactly written
together that's right I was going to to
ask you about he talked about getting
West Virginia out of all the ESG
companies saying we're not going to do
contracts with them these companies were
saying we will not provide financing for
the oil industry for the coal industry
for fossil fuels and that's West
Virginia strong point of West Virginia
so he said then get out we need to see
more of that here's here's a I mean this
this is going to be probably getting too
boring and Technical for you guys but I
think I've learned is a lot of the state
treasurers have been making a lot of
noise turns out they don't have a ton of
power I I hope I don't upset some of
them by saying this I'm just going to
call it like I see it the real money is
in the pension fund systems right so
what the state treasurers have is like a
pittance they'll move a few hundred
million dollars which sounds a lot on
Fox news.com headline but is actually a
pittance compared to a 20 trillion
dollar problem where the tens or
hundreds of billions are actually in the
pension systems and there you have
politically insulated actors right you
have actors who are designed to be not
responsive to the will of the everyday
citizens that are through layers and
layers of appointments the people who
sit on those bureaucratic bodies that's
really where the decisions get made so
you know even even that Florida decision
they pulled two billion from BlackRock
or whatever that was mostly cash and
short-term like fixed income like like
lending instruments nothing to do with
the equity problem which is owning
stocks and actually telling companies
how to behave that's in a different part
of a state bureaucracy's apparatus and
it's again the same problem that we're
talking about with the federal
government the whole FBI issue it's the
same issue here too where the people who
we elect to run the government are
really good at projecting to the public
that they're able to exercise actual
political power
when in fact that only deepens the
problem because they're not even the
ones who are exercising the real
political power which is a bureaucratic
technocracy that sits up beneath the
level of detection that's really where
the meat is it absolutely is a political
bureaucracy and I know you're right that
it's not left versus right as simple as
that but once more these these
structures that actually extend to
things like Pension funds I don't think
we can Overlook that yeah these are all
leftists right so the thing with the
leftist activists is that they are not
just at their job they are a leftist
activist at their job but that is
exactly why something like an ESG score
even exists in the first place and so
what is frustrating to me with the right
is that okay we are trying to further
our agenda by saying let's not be
political a lot of the times and a lot
of time that's all that the right is
asking for is just political neutrality
I would like to see the right fight back
a little bit more and say no that's
actually not enough right it's actually
not just enough to say oh we're going to
care about finances and not that your
your firm should be in this but
individual companies I would love to see
more of them actually say Hang on we're
actually afraid to say something that's
pro-abortion we want to be pro-life
because we know otherwise we're going to
be upsetting the conservative consumer
base just as much as we be we would be
upsetting the left-wing rabid regressive
consumer base but unfortunately the
right is still not on the same cultural
level that the left is in that regard
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time